today another step closer to cannabis
lounges opening here in southern nevada
yeah the cannabis compliance board
officially voted on the rules and
regulations for those lounges joe mohler
is near valley view and d-i with what
happened in that meeting today joe
well after a year of public workshops
the board approved the rules and
regulations for the cannabis lounges and
the process for the applications now
businesses around the valley including
nevada wellness center here are eager to
get these lounges open
there isn't a legal place to smoke it
frank hawkins owns nevada wellness
center we have a dispensary on the
bottom
consumption lounge is on the top tuesday
he learned more about the rules and
regulations that are now in place for
future lounges something he has been
setting up for in the upstairs of the
building next we'll be opening up the
consumption lounge after more than a
dozen public workshops the board voted
on finalizing the cannabis lounge
regulations and the rules for the
application process over the next few
months they expect to have informational
workshops before the application process
opens and then we'll send a 30-day
notice out
that i'll initiate
so 30-day notice for an open application
period cannabis compliance board
executive director tyler klimas says
they expect 40 to 45 applications for
lounges attached to retail shops and 20
independent shops 10 of which will go to
social equity applicants klymus
explained what that means what we're
looking for the impacts
of drug policy on individuals and
members of the community
and so we're looking at
poverty level
we're looking at any kind of past
convention convictions for cannabis just
some of the regulations include safety
protocols at lounges training
requirements for staff and location
requirements for the lounges that
includes certain distances from
locations such as schools and community
facilities hawkins is now one step
closer to getting a lounge open so the
consumption lounges are going to go a
long way for making a difference
so when could we see the first lounges
opening uh with the application process
likely starting in the next few months
klima says he expects to see the first
lounge open by the end of the year
reporting live joe mulder live local now